oh [__] this time for death [__]
pilot the [__] Bombardier
spoken if you're done with not going on
with your [__] muddy friends talking
about whatever the [__] you talking
about
are you [__] kidding me or what uncle
Joey here if a little late afternoon
[__] tape Taipei with you exclusive
from Sunset herbal killing [__]
for the last three months how do you
smoke weed for the last three months and
every time you go over there it's
[__] on fire let's do another one
here this is just tremendous - my wife
should make a little salad a little
grilled chicken yours I never get the
appetite going I got a spot at the store
them on tonight 11 o'clock we're doing
the podcast tomorrow at 8:00 you know
how we do it mother [__] when you're
creeping when you're sleeping uncle
Joey's creeping with his little [__]
half of fat green shirt
winds blowing out here tonight tough to
smoke the [__] I figured out these
get a hit heat [__] and say hey
what's going on and forget about you
[__] you know I'm gone a few
days you guys Joey where are you I can't
smoke but I you get your [__] together
you smoke with or without uncle Joey on
[__] the man you understand you know
worried about some [__] old fat [__]
the smoke put smoke on your own what the
[__] I'm just here with you guys you
know dick around smoke a ball joy what's
with the chitty-chat a spot that soda
pop the police's breathing techniques on
the [__] money I'm gonna like a
minute holding my breath I could
breathing and I'm doing the exercise and
put the [__] kettlebell on my stomach
let it all out
blow out the carbon [__] monoxide I
got a big stomach by the [__] hot air
and that [__] carbon monoxide
and reefer smoke dead [__] farts and
chicken cutlet juice whatever the [__]
I like it I like it don't need to drink
I don't need to do DMT I need to do
nothing as long as makeup my favorite
Goomba [__] all you [__] uncle
Joey straight-up only child I got a
[__] parade going out of my head at
all [__] times you understand anyway
I just want that them with you
[__] see what somebody oh yeah
this [__] reefer is on fire
I'm happy you [__] tune them
you know how we do it 24/7 I'll tap into
your [__] see was
crack-a-lackin' yeah
I got no pep talk about his night time
what do you want from me you wash your
[__] you cut your [__] toenails you
watch TV with your wife whatever you eat
[__] and you go to bed you lost you
want from me you want wisdom and I am
NOT for you
it's time for another one and I'm saying
what the [__] either you smoke anything
staring with your friends like look at
Joey you mean something I don't need no
[__] help I got all the help I can
get right here jingle bells Batman
smells how are you everything good good
things are bad although one more out of
respect I can't leave you guys hanging
besides I want to eat
bleep beer let's [__] do one more like
the savages that we are like gentlemen
look at us
did you have a [__] dream with the
papen every night all of us could smoke
Annamma
meanwhile these guys are doing [__]
card tricks on periscope they just suck
my dick
well we had taken it to the next [__]
level
got Planes Trains I don't give a [__]
how you doing lady now Wiz Khalifa wants
to smoke dope with uncle Joey I'm
telling you we're [__] smoking him up
who gives a [__] out he ain't count I
don't give a [__] if I was in the desert
I would listen I don't give a [__] I
like smoking my reefer cracking my jokes
doing podcast to hang with my family I
don't bother nobody
you don't see me out there jumping up
and down if I don't get the [__] I don't
need to put up amis I don't want to see
these [__] jerk-offs I want to go to
the comedy store I'm gonna smoke dope
I'm gonna go to jujitsu and that's it I
wish had mafia I can sit here for smoke
up your ass but [__] ain't got time
for that [__] I'm just not tired
you're a bad [__] going there
wash your toes do whatever the [__] you
need to do tomorrow's another day
whatever happened today who gives a [__]
mañana tomorrow's another day
come on another chance to take that
[__] to understand and that's it
everybody sweat it who gives a [__]
Trump just won East Coast and you can
you got [__] problems on anyway hit
o'clock tomorrow and I've got a nice
podcast tomorrow coming in the morning
we'll check then we hit Amaro morning
will smoke a few [__] numbers leaps
and stars tomorrow night and I said you
know I love you [__]
Indianapolis get your [__] together
does uncle Joey's coming big the [__]
stars already landed in Indy
my boys got him in his house a hundred
of them was [__]
does I'm gonna be bouncing up and down
Indianapolis always so whoever the [__]
you coming in from Chicago Atlanta the
Middle East I don't give a [__]
we're rockin [__] Indianapolis
this region I tell you guys I'm stoned
to the gills as long as you know that
I'm pretty [__] high right now after
then I'm gonna drop a few [__] stars
of death I'm in training and that's it I
seen [__] at the Comedy Store
not I see you tomorrow morning nice and
narrowly at attention I don't want no
[__] stories ready to smoke dope and
[__] see the future